It comes to energy.
We have a long way to go before our utility bills become a
thing of the past on the Carta chef's scale,
we're still a type zero civilization,
but we're closer than ever to harnessing Earth's energies.
So what would it take for us to become a type two or
stellar civilization?
How could we harness the energy of our son?
What could prevent us from getting to the next level on the scale
and how would our lives change?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we became a type two civilization,
okay. If you're new to the car to Chev scale, to put it simply,
it's a way to measure a civilization's level of technological advancement based
on the amount and types of energy that it can use has a type
zero civilization. We are a sub global culture,
meaning we still get the majority of our energy from organic sources like
wood, coal, and oil in order to reach type work.
One, we'll have to master the use of all the forms of energy on earth,
not just fossil fuels
with many advancements in solar, wind,
hydro and geothermal power. We're almost there
to earn a type two rating on the scale.
We'd need to be able to use all the power of our son.
So what could we do with it
in order to become a type two or stellar civilization,
we'll need to build a massive swarm of energy,
collecting satellites around the sun, known as a Dyson swarm.
You can learn more about this in our other video.
What if we built a Dyson sphere around our sun,
but before we start building,
we will have to improve a lot of things here on earth.
There are many potential dangers to humanity that could stop us in our tracks,
including climate change or pandemics,
and even asteroids. Speaking of asteroids,
NASA has been hard at work,
developing their dark project or double asteroid redirection test.
In 2021,
NASA will launch the dark satellite on a collision course with the near earth
asteroids, Diddy moon,
which orbits the larger and more threatening asteroid Diddy Moss.
This collision will increase Diddy moons, orbital speed by about four minutes,
which is just enough time to alter the larger asteroid Moss's
trajectory away from earth.
Creating the first artificial meteor shower.
If this proves to be a successful defense against threatening asteroids,
it could help us pave the way to becoming a type one civilization and
eventually type two. If we're lucky, mind you.
If we had the power of our entire sun at our fingertips,
we could simply vaporize any potential threats to our planet. In fact,
we could move earth out of harm's way. If we wanted to,
theoretically, we could control the orbits of everything in our solar system.
Using a Dyson swarm could also make other planets more habitable
with the help of these solar satellites.
We could carefully control any planet's temperature by redirecting the sun's
energy.
We could start terraforming nearby planets to give us new places to live.
This would even let us take interplanetary vacation,
anyone up for a ski trip to Mars. In fact,
why stop at Mars with limitless solar energy at our disposal,
we can travel almost anywhere in our solar system
technology. At this point would likely make space,
travel available and affordable to everyone. Right now,
a ticket to space could cost anywhere from $250,000 to
tens of millions of dollars. There's so much for my mortgage.
We might even be able to solve our climate change problems by partially
shading the earth with the Dyson sphere,
giving us time to heal and rebuild our atmosphere
with no more air pollution from fossil fuels.
We'd be a much healthier and happier species,
but before you breathe easy,
we have a lot of work to do here on earth before we even become a type one
civilization. And as you may have guessed,
that's a story for another, what else.